this movie's power level was over 9 000
faster than a bullet train and stronger
than a beast here's how dragon ball
super went super saiyan at the box
office
this weekend brought the surprising news
that the number one box office hit in
america is an anime feature film the
movie in question is dragon ball super
superhero based on the long-running and
enormously popular dragon ball franchise
and the 21st feature film in the dragon
ball saga overall on august 21st the
hollywood reporter announced that dragon
ball super superhero is the number one
movie in the country and according to
its distributor crunchyroll its opening
weekend haul of over 20 million dollars
is enough to make it the best global box
office debut in history for an anime in
theaters the movie opened on more than 3
100 screens across north america and it
handily beat out its major new release
competition like the thriller beast
which sees idris elba fighting off a
lion and slightly older releases like
bullet trains starring brad pitt one
advantage that dragon ball super
superhero had over its competition is
that even though we're still technically
in the summer blockbuster season movie
premieres were light heading into the
weekend with only beast starring idris
elba opening it debuted with a
relatively modest 10 million dollars the
hollywood reporter called that a
disappointing start but on the upside
for anime fans this did allow dragon
ball super superhero to take the top
slot and make anime history in the
process both dragon ball super superhero
and beast were targeted towards similar
audiences while beast reportedly skewed
56 percent mail in its proportion of
opening weekend ticket buyers the
audience for superhero was significantly
more so at almost 80 percent mail the
film was also a success among that ever
important younger demographic as 70 of
its opening weekend audience were
reportedly between the ages of 18 and
35. if you know anything about the
appeal of the dragon ball franchise that
shouldn't come as a surprise in fact
much of the film's current success might
well be attributed to that age group's
nostalgia for the now classic animated
series
power levels
wait it's over nine the beloved anime
dragon ball z first hit american tv in
1996 which means that many who grew up
watching the series are now old enough
to have children of their own nostalgia
is a powerful force and it's impossible
to discount it when dragon ball super
superhero has done so well with such a
wide release in theaters the nostalgic
appeal of dragon ball super superhero
was no surprise for the cast and crew
that helped bring the movie to the us
speaking to showbiz cheat sheet to
promote the film members of its english
language voice cast like zach aguilar
jason marnoka and sean shemel spoke
about this very thing they spoke about
how they were delighted to come on board
the film as childhood fans of dragon
ball z as explained by aguilar who
voiced dr hedo in the movie it's been so
surreal growing up watching the show i
watched it in middle school at every
stage of the process i would say
constantly i've had to pinch myself like
am i dreaming is this actually real am i
actually a part of dragon ball marnoka
who plays carmine had a similar
experience saying i'm kind of in a
similar boat you know i grew up watching
dragon ball z and things like that so i
had an understanding of this world and
the red ribbon army and these characters
and things going in which i don't
usually have when the cast of a movie
has such nostalgic feelings for its
source material one hopes the audience
will too if the film's box office
performance is any indication those
designs were a resounding success
[Music]